it's good methodological practice
whenever you're
starting to build new models to start by
evaluating very simple models which
establish baselines to which you can
then compare the more sophisticated
models that you're going to build later
on
so to do that we're going to start by
looking at three simple models a random
guesser
a very simple phrase matching strategy
and then our first machine learning
based approach which will be a simple
bag of words classifier
just about the simplest possible model
is one that doesn't even look at the
input but just flips a coin and i
strongly encourage you whenever you're
embarking on a model building adventure
in your final project wherever
start by evaluating a random guesser
it's a snap to implement it can help to
work out the kinks in your test harness
and it's often very informative to put a
floor under what good scores look like
now we've written an evaluation method
for you it's in the relics module and
it's just called evaluate
you invoke it with your splits
your classifier
and
the name of the split that you want to
evaluate on which defaults to dev
when we evaluate our random guesser we
have some interesting results so we have
uh results separated for each of the
relations
and for each one we have precision
recall f score remember that's f 0.5
which gives more weight to precision
than to recall
we have the support which is the number
of instances whose actual label is true
and we have size which is just the total
number of instances
we find that recall is generally right
around 0.5
and this makes sense because recall says
of the instances which are actually true
what proportion do we predict true well
we predict true about half the time
because we're just flipping a coin
precision on the other hand is generally
quite poor
because precision says of the instances
where we predict true
which are basically a random sample
because we're just flipping a coin
how many are actually true
well relatively few and actually you can
tell that by looking at the ratio
between support and size the ratio
between support and size
is how many of the instances are
actually true
so when we're cos tossing a coin
the precision should be right around the
ratio between support and
size
uh our f score is also generally poor it
stays close to precision
for two reasons number one because the
harmonics the harmonic mean stays closer
to the lower number
and number two because we're using f 0.5
which gives more weight to precision
than to recall
and the bottom line our macro average f
score is 9.7
so that's the number to beat
it's a pretty low bar
but this is a random guesser after all
okay so let's look at another approach
which is very simple but smarter than
random guessing and it's a simple
pattern matching strategy and the idea
is for each relation
let's go through the corpus
and find the most common phrases
that connect two entities that stand in
that relation the most common middles in
our terminology
so here's some code that does that
i won't go through it in detail
but one thing to note is that it counts
separately
the middles that connect subject with
object so here it gets all the examples
and
um
counts the middles it tallies up the
middles
and it does that separately from the
examples that connect object with
subject
and it stores them in several separate
um dictionaries under the keys forward
and reverse so we're going to have
forward middles and reverse middles
stored separately stored and counted
separately
if we run that code here's what we get
i'm showing results i'm only going to
show results for three of the relations
here not all 16.
all 16 are in the the python notebook if
you want to take a look but even from
this sample there's a few things that
jump out
first some of the most frequent middles
are really natural and intuitive
for example
comma starring
indicates a reverse film performance
relation
um so that would be one where the film
comes first and the actor comes second
um i think that makes perfect sense uh
star wars
comma starring mark hamill
similarly comma son of
indicates a forward parent's relation so
this would be one where the son comes
first the child comes first and the
parent comes second
so those are extremely intuitive and
it's reassuring to see them
near the top of the list of most common
middles
another observation is that punctuation
and stop words like comma
and and
are extremely common
unlike
some other nlp applications it's
probably a bad idea to throw these away
they carry lots of useful information
on the other hand punctuation and stop
words tend to be highly ambiguous
for example if you look across the full
range of all 16 relations you'll see
that a bear comma
is a likely middle for almost every
relation in at least one direction
so that comma does very often indicate a
relation but it's a really ambiguous
indicator
okay now that we've identified the most
common middles for each relation it's
straightforward to build a classifier
based on that information a classifier
that predicts true
for a candidate kb triple
just in case the two entities in the
triple appear in the corpus connected by
one of the phrases that we just
discovered
i don't show the code for that here but
it's in the python notebook for this
unit
and when we evaluate this approach we
see some really interesting results
first recall is much worse across the
board and that makes sense because we're
no longer just guessing randomly before
we were saying true half the time
now we're going to be a lot more
selective about what we say true to
but precision
and f score have improved dramatically
for several relations
especially for a joins and author and
has sibling and has spouse
then again there are many other
relations where precision and f score
are still quite poor
including this one genre where we get
straight zeros across the board i'm not
quite sure what happened there
but it indicates that although
although things have improved a lot in
some places
they're still rather poor in others
and our macro average f score has
improved only modestly so it improved
from 9.7 percent to 11.1 percent we're
heading in the right direction but you'd
have to say that's still pretty
unimpressive
to make significant gains we're going to
need to apply machine learning
so let's get started on that we're going
to build a very simple classifier using
an approach that should be familiar
from our look at sentiment analysis last
week
and we're going to start that by
defining a very simple bag of words
feature function
so here's the code for that
and let me briefly walk you through it
what we're going to do is to get the
features for a kb triple that's the kbt
here
we're going to find all of the corpus
examples
containing the two entities in the kb
triple the subject and the object and
note that we do that in both directions
subject subject and object and then also
object and subject
for each example we look at the middle
we break it into words
and then we count up all the words
so couple things to note here one is
that the feature representation for one
kb triple
can be derived from many corpus examples
and this is the point that i was trying
to make uh last time
that we're using the corpus to generate
features for a candidate kb triple
and the role of the corpus
is to provide the feature representation
and the feature representation for a kb
triple will be based on all of the
examples in the corpus that contain
those two entities
the other observation to make here is
that we make no distinction between
what you might call forward examples
which have subject first and then object
and reverse examples which have object
and then subject we're lumping them all
together
the words that come from the middles of
examples in either direction all get
lumped together into one feature counter
and you might have qualms about whether
that's really the smartest thing to do
so let's get a sense of what this looks
like in action
first let's print out the very first kb
triple in rkb
we actually looked at this last time
it's a kb triple that says that
the contains relation holds between
brickfields and kuala lumpur central
railway station
um and now let's look up the first
example
containing these two entities so i'm
just going to look them up in the
forward direction subject and object i
get all the examples uh i look at the
first one and let me just print out the
middle the middle says it was just a
quick 10-minute walk too so i guess the
full example probably said something
like
from brickfields it was just a quick
10-minute walk to kuala lumpur central
railway station
and maybe there was more
um
now let's run our featurizer on this kb
triple and see what features we get
uh so we get a counter that contains it
was just a quick 10 minute walk to the
so it looks like it's counted up the
words in that middle which is just what
we expected
if but if you look closely there's
something unexpected here because the
word two has a count of two
even though it appears only once in that
middle and also the word the has a count
of 1 even though it didn't appear in
that middle at all
so where did those come from
well remember that the futurizer counts
words from the middles of all examples
containing those entities in either
direction
and it turns out that the corpus
contains another example containing
those two entities and that other
example has
there's just one other example but that
other example has middle to the
and so that's where these counts come
from
so all is well it did the right thing
okay we have our simple bag of words
featurizer now we need a way to train
models
to make predictions and to evaluate the
results uh the relics module contains
functions for each of those and so i
just want to give you a quick tour
of what those functions are
but you'll definitely want to go read
the the code for this so that you're
more familiar with
how it can be used and a lot of this
code appears in a file called rel x rel
underscore x dot pi
so we'll start with a function called
train models
this takes as arguments the dictionary
of data splits a list of featurizers and
here we have a list consisting of just
our simple bag of words featurizer
the name of the split on which to train
which defaults to train
and a model factory which is a function
that returns a
a classifier
and it's
sorry a function which initializes an sk
classifier and by default it's a
logistic regression classifier as shown
here but you could easily substitute
this with some other sksk learn
classifier
it returns
this thing called train result which is
a dictionary holding the featurizers the
vectorizer that was used to generate the
training matrix and most importantly a
dictionary holding the trained models
one per relation so it's a dictionary
which maps from relation names to models
so that's train models
next comes predict
this is a function that takes as
arguments a dictionary of data splits
the output of trained models that train
result thing
and the name of the split on which to
make predictions and by default that's
dev
and it returns two parallel dictionaries
one holds the predictions grouped by
relation
and the other holds the true labels
grouped by relation
and our third building block is evaluate
predictions so this is a function that
takes as arguments the two parallel
dictionaries of predictions and true
labels produced by predict
and it prints evaluation metrics for
each relation like we saw earlier
now before we dwell on these results i
want to show one more function
which is a function called experiment
and experiment simply chains together
the three functions that i just showed
you it changed together training
prediction and evaluation
so that's very convenient for running
end-to-end experiments
i haven't shown all the parameters here
but if you go look at the source code
you'll see that it actually takes a lot
of optional parameters and those
parameters let you specify
everything about how to run the
experiment let you specify your
featurizers your model factory which
splits to train and test on and more so
for example earlier i mentioned that the
tiny split is really useful for running
fast experiments to work out the kinks
if you wanted to do that it's very easy
using the experiment function just to
set the training split and the test
split to tiny to run a very quick
experiment
now here are the results of evaluating
our simple bag of words logistic
regression classifier and let's take a
closer look because
this is quite stunning
even though this is just about the
simplest possible classifier
we've achieved huge gains over the
phrase matching approach
the first thing that jumps out is that
our macro average f score has jumped
from 11.1 to 56.7
and we see big gains in precision for
almost every single relation
and correspondingly big gains in f score
on the other hand there's still plenty
of room for improvement i mean this is
much
uh much more impressive than where we
were before but we're very far from
perfection there's abundant headroom and
opportunity to continue to improve